[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a des millénaires les anciens du
honte insuffler à l'âme de nos aïeux une
vision du monde
ainsi est née la culture indo-européenne
cette culture oral riche et très
structurée s'est diffusé au fil du temps
sur toute l'Europe et une partie de
l'Asie
traversant l'âge du bronze les porteurs
de cette identité ont façonné nos
cultures ethniques et les nations à
venir de notre continent
de cet arbre immense l'une des branches
et la mythologie celtique
en Gaule les bruits de regrouper dans
clergé en célébrer le fils religieux
tandis que les barbes en chantait les
roses et les yeux
d'abord païenne cette culture c'est
ensuite christianiser en Occident
Le Point de Bascule se situe dans les
brumes des 3e 4e siècle quand la société
occidentale passe peu à peu du paganisme
au christianisme
l'empereur Gaulois posthume vers 260 et
encore païen ces belles et nombreuses
monnaie témoins du culte qu'il rend
notamment à Hercule
l'empereur romain Dioclétien païen aussi
déclenche vers 301 persécution contre
les chrétiens surtout en Orient
au final le christianisme l'emporte avec
Constantin quoique païens Constantin
c'est officiellement entrée l'Empire
dans la civilisation chrétienne en 313
à partir du 4e siècle la Gaule glisse
progressivement de la culture celtique
païenne à la culture celtique chrétienne
car le christianisme n'a pas remplacé le
paganisme celtique il l'a plutôt
embrasser accompli sans insigne synthèse
harmonieuse que l'on va retrouver durant
tout le au Moyen-Âge
par exemple le due aux oiseaux des
anciens Gaulois se conserver quasi un
changé dans des églises médiévale comme
le montre à relief Payen de Dijon et des
chapiteaux de Saint-Germain-des-Prés à
Paris
le dieu porte 2 oiseau perché sur ses
épaules et les oiseaux ont les becs
tourné dans le visage malgré les siècles
la transmission culturelle de l'ancien
paganisme vers le christianisme est ici
évidente
[Musique]
cette époque encore mal connues demeure
en grande partie inexplorés
[Musique]
durant la basse antiquité et le au
Moyen-Âge la culture est orale
douce et décor énigmatique que
n'explique aucun texte
[Musique]
cervidé sanglier Centaure sirène Lyon
monstre à double corps gueule de
jaillisse des rasso tête parmi les
feuillages hommes-oiseaux et sommes
plantes peuple ta foison les murs de nos
ancienne église
[Musique]
un second changement de paradigme
culturelle aura lieu beaucoup plus tard
l'accoutumance à l'écrit va favoriser
l'intimité avec la Bible
à partir du 12e siècle abandonnant la
tradition orale le clergé ira chercher
son inspiration dans le Nouveau
Testament est dans l'ancien d'autres
références culturelles tirer dessin
d'écriture
c'est alors et alors seulement que le
christianisme celtique mystique et
Rurale tombera en désuétude remplacé par
le christianisme biblique littéraire et
urbain
ce point de bascule terminale coïncide
avec les croisades et les cathédrales
gothiques
ainsi en France la religieux de cette
époque connaître deux changements
majeurs
au 4e siècle on passe du Celtic païen au
Celtic chrétien
et au 12e siècle on passe du Celtic
chrétien à la culture biblique
dans les contrées celtiques l'avancée du
christianisme se fait presque
naturellement la Gaule a été en pointe
des le 4e siècle avec notamment
Saint-Martin
l'Irlande excentré insulaire est hors de
l'Empire c'est pourtant très vite
christianiser des le 5e siècle avec
Saint-Patrick
il existe un lien consubstantiel entre
identité culturelle des Celtes et
chrétienté naissante puis médiéval
l'historienne Régine Pernoud avait déjà
mise en avant ce phénomène au cœur de
notre identité nationale
par sa formation d'archiviste Régine
Pernoud et tu dis pas seulement les
conséquences et cherche surtout à
remonter au cause
la société médiévale dans ses coutumes
dans son expression artistique continue
la société celtique son ancêtre
en France la ville médiévale et en effet
fille naturelle de la vie celtique
maintes objet nous en vient comme en
témoigne l'habillement religieux
militaire au civil
le manteau à capuchon des Celtes est
devenu la coule des moines et le manteau
de pèlerin
[Musique]
la côte de maille des guerriers gaulois
a été adopté d'abord par la légion
romaine puis par la chevalerie médiévale
quand Aubrey elles sont devenu notre
pantalon les Romains que portait la toge
au repas nous mangeons Zazie telle les
Gaulois tandis que les Romains manger
coucher
dans le transport des liquides les
Gaulois ont inventé le tonneau à la fois
robuste et facile à rouler très
supérieur en cela aux enfoires
méditerranéenne cassable est malaisé
s'arranger
dans le métier des armes la valeur de la
parole donnée et le code de la
chevalerie sont un héritage celtique et
germanique
la puissance morale de l'église qui
sanctifie ou excommunie même des rois
présente une continuité évidente avec
l'ancien pouvoir des druides où existait
déjà les mêmes prérogatives
[Musique]
le grec Posidonius repris par César il
s'est clairement référence
c'est un particulier ou un peuple ne
s'en tient pas à leur décision les
bruits de lui interdit les sacrifices
c'est la peine la plus lourde chez les
Gaulois
l'édifice très fonctionnel de la société
féodale reprend quasi à l'identique
celui de la société gauloise avec les
trois fonctions indo-européennes
le clergé anciennement les druides la
noblesse anciennement les guerriers le
tiers-état anciennement le poke
dans l'intervalle l'Empire romain aurait
été un régime administratif fiscal et
militaire
mais son pouvoir superficiel n'aura
jamais me pénétrer les campagnes me
changer la mentalité des populations
la renaissance de la culture celtique au
Moyen-Âge s'explique en fait par sa
propre constance durant l'Empire romain
on devrait peut-être parler de culture
profonde pour désigner la mais les
traditions d'un peuple et sa pérennité
est unique au-delà des changements
politiques voir religieux
la pérennité des us et coutumes
celtiques se vérifie dans les actes les
plus politique des l'intronisation
Populaire d'un nouveau souverain
au milieu du 4e siècle la frontière du
Rhin connaît de nombreuses alertes du
fait de l'intrusion constante de peuple
germanique
la garde du territoire et alors confié à
Julien neveu de Constantin 1er
en 355 à seulement 14 ans Julien reçoit
le titre de César c'est-à-dire VI
empereur
décrit comme nerveux hésitant es timide
Julien brille toutefois par son sérieux
et sa probité
dans les camps militaire le jeune homme
partage la vie de ses soldats ce qui le
rend populaire
après plusieurs campagnes victorieuses
il parvient à refouler les Alamans
au-delà du Rhin
[Musique]
c'est alors que va se produire une scène
étonnante rapporté par l'historien grec
de langue latine Amiens Marcel
selon son habitude Julien stationne avec
ses troupes à Lutèce quand il reçoit une
missive en provenance de rien elle est
de l'empereur constance 2
en difficulté contre les Perses
constance réclame à Julien l'envoi de de
légion
se tordre et lourdes danger car il
suppose de dégarnir la frontière
nord-est de la Gaule frontière du Rhin
qu'on a eu tant de peine à rétablir
contre les assauts barbares
quand tes troupes gauloise après la
nouvelle c'est l'émeute durant la nuit
les Gaulois se rendre au palais et aclam
Julien du titre d'empereur en lieu et
place du lointain constance 2 et la
scène d'intronisation va se passer selon
les techniques du pays
on fait monter le jeune César sur un
bouclier puis on le hisse en l'air sous
les applaudissements
[Musique]
comme il faut aussi le coiffer d'une
couronne honorifique un self d'états
sont orques et Metz collier sacré sur la
tête de Julien
Julien et ainsi proclamé empereur par
ses troupes gauloise à Lutèce selon
lentilles coutume 17
on place à Julien sur un bouclier de
fantassin puis soulever bien où on le
proclame à Augusta plaît ne vois ils
m'ont ordonné qui est Horta le diadème à
certains mort des tâches à son top qu'il
utilisait comme un signe et le posa
hardiment sur la tête de Julien
Le Thor qui est un collier Celtic
sûrement gravure on peut voir des
divinité gauloise pour tes 7 ornements
sacré soit autour du cou soit autour du
bras soit le brandir comme ici le Dieu
car ninos
cette coutume locale de hisser le chef
sur le pavois sera reprise une centaine
d'années plus tard parler franc
en 510 après que Clovis s'est emparé de
Cologne il se fera ici sur le bouclier
est acclamé par les Francs rhénan
après avoir entendu le discours de
Clovis les Francs l'applaudit et
l'acclame il élève sera bouclier et en
font leur propre roi
il ne fait aucun doute que les coutumes
des Celtes on perd durée non seulement
durant l'Empire romain mais aussi
au-delà
l'élévation royale à la gauloise
concerne et Julien est Clovis par une
curieuse ambiguïté de l'histoire il
s'agit du dernier empereur païen Julien
et du premier roi catholique Clovis
au sortir de la chute de l'Empire romain
d'Occident le roi des Francs Clovis se
convertit à la croyance de ces sujets en
496 la Gaule devient la France
catholique
petit alors l'Antiquité commence le au
Moyen-Âge
dit ainsi tout paraît simple
mets archéologue l'historien de la on
toujours du maille à partir pour dater
identifier et nommer les œuvre de cette
époque à la fois ancien peu documenté et
être uniquement complexe
pour mal connaître c'est mal nommer les
choses
dès le 19e siècle aux prémices de la
science archéologique on se met à
appeler un roman tout ce qui sort d'un
au Moyen-Âge dans ton ne sais rien
le terme roman a été maladroitement
donné par l'archéologue Charles de
Gerville qui en 1818 écrivait dans une
lettre à un ami
tout le monde convient que cette
architecture lourde et grossière et le
pouce romane dénaturé ou successivement
dégradé par morue les ancêtres
au pouce Romanum signifie ouvrage romain
la roman serai donc un à Romain décadent
sauf que l'on se rendit compte assez
vite qu'il n'y avait aucune similitudes
entre 7ar particulier et là réellement
romain
face au mystère mat historien accueilli
déceler ça et là des influences
étrangères parfois très lointaine
orientale sans succès
rejetant le terme roman inapproprié
Régine Pernoud propose de nommer cette
art celto chrétien
il est probable que les recherches
futures d'aboutir ont qu'à faire mieux
découvrir encore le lien étroit de notre
littérature médiévale au mythe de
l'Antiquité celtique mais c'est
évidemment dans le domaine artistique
que l'on peut le mieux percevoir cette
continuité de l'inspiration Celtic à
l'aspiration médiévale on est allé
chercher bien loin les origines de notre
à Romans n'était-il pas naturel pour
temps de voir en lui un harcèle de
chrétiens l'une et l'autre source les
sens d'ailleurs entière son originalité
Massy Lardy roman apparaît moins comme
la dégradation du génie romain que comme
le réveil du génie gaulois et catholique
sinon quand une échelle large la
floraison de ses églises celtique
s'étend du 4e siècle au 12e siècle
souvent méconnu elle croit surtout dans
les lieux reculer loin des grosses
villes
elles parsèment tout le territoire de
l'ancien Gaulle voir au-delà
quand on étudie l'Antiquité une période
apparaît comme un trou noir et une
mystérieuse matrix le 3e siècle
[Musique]
le 3e siècle est un entre deux mondes
à la fin du 2e siècle l'empereur
Marc-Aurèle fait encore figure de Prince
philosophe dans un monde païen équilibré
au début du 4e siècle l'empereur
Constantin ouvre la brèche à la
civilisation chrétienne entre ces deux
empereurs le 3e siècle connais une crise
existentielle 100 =
de 235 à 284 cv la période de la
monarchie militaire parsemé d'une
myriade de petit empereur à la foire
Ivoz éphémère
et au cœur de l'anarchie militaire de
260 à 274 se trouve l'époque des 3
empire
l'Empire Gaulois réunis goal Bretagne et
Ibérie
l'empire de Palmyre les terres d'Orient
et l'Egypte l'Empire romain se réduite à
l'espace centrale
le premier l'historien de France
Grégoire de Tours situe précisément à
l'époque de l'anarchie militaire les
premières grande mission évangélique en
Gaule
soul empereur death de nombreuses c'est
le vert contre le nom chrétien en ce
temps cet homme ordonné évêque sur
t'envoyer préférant goal
C7 Pioneer répondre la Parole de Dieu en
Gaule durant la marche militaire et
l'Empire Gaulois leur chef serait
Saint-Denis de Paris
et l'initiateur de cette apostolat le
pape Fabien
serait car les documents d'époque et que
les asticots laïcs font défaut quant aux
sources elles sont rares et tardive que
l'on songe de Grégoire de Tours écrit
sur ce sujet trois siècles plus tard en
se basant sur des sources aujourd'hui
invérifiable
ce qui est probable en revanche ce sont
les grandes lignes directrices
car c'est bien au crépuscule du 3e
siècle que s'amorce la montée en
puissance de la chrétienté
[Musique]
l'émergence de la chrétienté se produit
toutefois dans un contexte de crise
sociale et politique commenter -
Grégoire de Tours pour la ville de
Bourges
les sénateurs de les élites du coin
était alors attaché au culte Pie en vrai
ce qui avait la foi était dans entre les
pauvres
ainsi l'illustre Saint-Martin et est
aussi populaire auprès des gens de la
campagne que persécutés par les évêques
des villes
c'est un élément essentiel la foi
chrétienne la puce sans racine est dans
le pays que grâce à la porte des masses
populaires donc des Gaulois ruraux
c'est-à-dire des gens attaché au terroir
et aux coutumes ancestral religieuse
culturelle ou funéraire
des gens paradoxalement sans lien
intellectuel avec les récits de la Bible
c'est ce christianisme là mais les deux
traditions autochtones qui voit le jour
sur notre terre
d'où l'art celtique qui va orner nos
églises
la société romaine païenne est
déboussolé au 3e siècle en sœur
finalement chrétienne et revigorer au 4e
siècle
débute aussi l'époque des grands
bâtisseurs
en boule Saint-Martin fondé premier
monastère d'Occident Ligugé en 360 et
Marmoutier quelques années plus tard
cette vie monacale avec ses ermite
vivant au contact de la nature va à la
diffusion du message chrétien auprès des
masses rurales
partout l'on voit surgir de terre des
églises
le plan d'une église est toujours le
même elle doit être orienté selon l'axe
s Ouest
son architecture recèle en effet une
symbolique solaire car par analogie Dieu
est la lumière du monde
en 470 à Tours à l'emplacement même du
tombeau de saint Martin leveques et une
basilique au proportion considérable
pour l'époque
Grégoire de Tours en témoignent
personnellement une centaine d'années
plus tard
l'effet que fit bâtir la grande
basilique qui subsiste encore
aujourd'hui et qui est à 900 m de la
ville elle a 50 m de long pour 20 m de
large elle a 15 m de haut jusqu'à la
voûte elle l'a 32 fenêtres vers l'hôtel
et 20 dans la nef avec 41 colonne dans
tous les 10 fils il y a 52 fenêtres 120
colonnes et 8 portes 3 vers l'hôtel et 5
dans la nef
cette somptueuse basilique non identifié
à ce jour est érigée en 470 soit 6 ans
seulement avant la chute officielle de
l'Empire romain d'Occident en 476
par la suite le royaume des Francs à sur
certes la relève mais constamment divisé
il peine à trouver l'équilibre et sombre
le plus souvent dans la guerre civile
le clergé représente alors la seule
autorité à peu près stable du pays
en plus du Salut des hommes le diocèse
s'occupe du social malades pauvre
orphelin et du bâtiment école hôpitaux
route
il se dégage alors un trou blanc
contraste entre la majestueuse grandeur
des œuvre du clergé et la permanente
anarchy d'abord de l'Empire romain puis
du royaume des Francs
sachant toutefois que les textes des
potes ont presque tous été écrit par des
Clercs à la fois juge et partie dans
l'historiographie
au 5e siècle l'évêque d'Auvergne Sana
masse fait construire la cathédrale de
Clermont
le nom de Damas est intéressant à
l'évidence il provient d'une racine
gauloise soit n'aime-t-on qui signifie
sanctuaire
Soanan tout ce qui signifie 9e
comme par enchantement la masse se
trouvait à la fois le bâtisseur d'un
sanctuaire la première cathédrale de
Clermont et le 9e évêque de Clermont
la racine aime ton sanctuaire commune au
peuple celtique se retrouve en Irlande
dans le livre des conquêtes d'Irlande il
est question d'un chef mythique du nom
donné m'aide considéré comme le roi du
peuple des cervidés
[Musique]
par ces liens avec le cerf Mémed et
l'équivalent en gaélique du Gaulois cœur
Munos le dieu druide à ramure de cerf
sur ces indices il est probable que
Saint-James à soit un personnage
composite mail en ancien mythologie
celtique et histoire chrétienne
qu'en est-il de la cathédrale de
Clermont
l'édifice décrit par Grégoire de Tours
mais pas celui d'aujourd'hui
sensiblement de même taille que la
mystérieuse basilique de Tours ce
sanctuaire présente une nouveauté
architecturale le transept
le transept est une perpendiculaire à la
nef principale vue du ciel l'église
quand alors au sol la forme d'une croix
souvent latine
conçu de parts et d'autres matériaux
raffiné tous les difficiles semble
établi à la façon d'une croix
un autre indice France est église
intéressante on y trouve des gravures
ciselées dans le marbre
vers l'hôtel les murs sont décorés de
bois s'isoler dans divers types de
marbre
on aurait été mis en savoir plus sur ses
marbres 6 allée
[Musique]
au vu des œuvre présente en général dans
les églises anciennes il s'agissait sans
doute de chapiteau historié et de frise
murale
quel sujet il y avait ton figuré
une ébauche de réponse se trouve chez
l'épouse de l'évêque n'amasse qui est
aussi une bâtisseuse
on lui doit tu une église dédiée à
Saint-Étienne non loin de Clermont
pour choisir le décor de son église
madame n'amasse me serais faire ni à la
Bible ni à des vies de saints comme on
aurait pu s'y attendre
mets un certain livre et ce livre
raconte d'antiques exploits qui sont les
sujets à faire figurer en couleur
l'épouse de Namasté construire hors des
murs de la ville la basilique
Saint-Etienne quand elle voulu l'emmener
de phare de couleur de Nantes en son
sein à livre et faisant la lecture des
histoires de l'ancien gestes et la vie
qui est au peintre lesquels il devait
façonner sur les murs
quel était donc ce mystérieux livre
l'ancien geste évoquent un recueil de
mythe ou de légende païenne
[Musique]
plus tard et Gina rapporte que
Charlemagne aurait commandé de mettre
sur parchemin les souvenirs héroïques de
la culture orale
les poèmes barbares des antique où était
chanter la geste et les garder ancien
roi Charlemagne le fit écrire pour les
confier à la mémoire
que sont devenus ses poèmes barbares et
antique
ils n'ont pas disparu
les chansons de geste françaises sont
des poèmes épiques écrit en vieux
français et daté pour la plupart des 11e
13e siècle
c'est texte puissance des passionnés
raconte les aventures chevaleresques de
Charlemagne et des 12 paires de France
[Musique]
il arrive parfois que des trouvères
répondre comme en écho aux paroles de
Grégoire de Tours et eginard
dans la Chanson de Roland la geste est
associé à Saint-Gilles le confesseur de
Charlemagne
incident il a juste et dit celui qui fut
sur le champ de bataille Gilles Le Saint
baron pour qui Dieu fait des miracles
c'est lui qui fait la charte du
monastère de l'an qui ne sais cela ne
l'a pas assez étudié
cette charte on l'appelle aussi la geste
fou encore ou geste des Francs elle est
à la source de la Chanson de Roland
tout le poème est parsemé de ce message
il est écrit dans la Jasse de Franck
orque bon guerrier une autre empereur
c'est ce que dit la geste
il est écrit en l'ancien geste
dans une version parallèle on évoque
aussi de vieux livres prophétique qui
aurait t'annoncer la bataille de
Roncevaux et ses conséquences
l'arche veux que tu repeins dit alors il
a été trouvé dans le vieux livre que
nous devions tomber sous le joug des
païens
ainsi il ne fait guère de doute que la
culture ethnique de la France sans
racine et se déploie au fil des siècles
l'ancien geste que Grégoire associé à
l'épouse de la masse au 5e siècle
remonte au temps de la Gaule avant même
la naissance de la France avec le
baptême de Clovis
c'est au culture Gallic on en retrouve
les structures sous-jacentes aussi bien
sur les chapiteaux de nos ancienne
église dit romane que dans les chansons
de geste
[Musique]
vers 285 St-Clair évangéliste
l'Armorique puis devient le premier
évêque de Nantes
plus tard l'évêque Felix fait bâtir la
cathédrale de Nantes qui est achevé en
567 c'est un bâtiment immense illuminé
de fenêtre est riche en figure coloré
Venance Fortunat évêque de Poitiers
donne une description détaillée de la
cathédrale de Nantes de cette époque
à la croisée du transept se dresse une
tour lanterne de forme carrée percée
d'ouverture qui procure un surcroît de
lumière dans le sanctuaire et sur
l'hôtel
échelonner d'étages en arcade l'édifice
se termine en route arrondi fait de
plaque d'étain
quand il fait soleil la toiture
s'illumine et les figures pinsons comme
animé d'une vie propre
la par l'animation des couleurs on
croirait véritable eraso est sous le
souffle artistique vivante les images
quand le soleil dans sa course donne de
la couleur au toi ton état ça rougeur
frappa entre jaillit temps lumière de
lait sous les ont dû le rayon on voit tu
allais revenir les figures et le plafond
de bouge comme l'eau de la mer au soleil
de son côté Grégoire de Tours apporte un
témoignage sur l'origine ethnique des
artisans qui ont-elles WC architecture
Grégoire confit qu'avant son accession à
l'évêché les flammes avait ravagé la
Cathédrale de Tours
aussi a-t-il commandé de l'art bâtir
avec autant de beauté qu'avant
et il a embauché pour se faire des
maître d'art Gaulois
ayant trouvé les murs de la salle de
basilic consumé par la Sandy j'ai
ordonné qu'ils fussent repas de orner
dans l'ancien magnificence par le soin
de nos maître d'art
incident et le 6e siècle en Gaule des
églises de taille importante présente
une architecture qui nous est familière
avec tour-lanterne transept arcade
fenêtre et colonnes
sous la main habile de maître d'oeuvre
Gaulois des figures colorées anime de
leur souffle minérale frisé chapiteau
l'historien d'art Émile mâle constatant
l'étrange contraste entre le régime
quasi anarchique des rois mérovingiens
et l'érection Touzazimut de bâtiment
somptueux dit de notre 6e siècle
ainsi dans cette Gaulle mérovingienne
qui de loin nous paraît vous et à
l'anarchie on construit partout si aux
églises on ajoute les monastères qui
commence à se lever de toute part on
sera amené à penser que ce 6e siècle fut
une des plus belles époques de
l'histoire de l'art chrétien en Gaule
selon les textes médiévaux en effet
l'une des plus belles époques de
l'histoire de l'art chrétien en Gaule
correspond au 6e siècle
pourtant selon l'archéologie officiel il
ne resterait aujourd'hui rien de ce
fameux 6e siècle
aucun beaux vestiges même en ruine
[Musique]
ce qui ne laisse pas de surprendre quand
on lit la dimension et la richesse
ornementale de c'est ancien édifice
en fait l'archéologie officiel si tu
sais belle époque de l'art chrétien au
11e 12e siècle
c'est l'Arcelle topchrétien au rhum
là où cela devient intéressant c'est que
c'est hard ATD 11e 12e siècle présente
des œuvre inattendues dans une église
désœuvré quasi païenne dans la facture
et à l'évidence archaïque
on dirait que les datation font en
double et en effet l'art que l'on peut
s'identifier comme celle topchrétien au
roman remonte plus ou moins selon les
chroniques au 6e siècle selon
l'archéologie officiel au 11e siècle
erreur de datation au siècle fantôme le
décalage complet entre texto source et
bâtiment réel ne laisse pas d'interroger
la question se posait donc au clergé de
savoir comment christianiser les masses
populaires
c'est-à-dire comment rassembler de leur
plein gré tous les hommes de bien
derrière le Christ
c'est pour résoudre ce dilemme religieux
que le pape Grégoire le Grand décide de
christianiser le paganisme
cela consiste à intégrer la parole du
Christ au coutume locale en adaptant si
besoin les symboles de l'ancien culte
aux préceptes de l'Évangile
de la sorte les sanctuaires païens se
métamorphose en Église
et les fêtes en l'honneur des anciens
dieux se mute en fait dessin les
attributs des premiers pas sans ton
second
le pape Grégoire le Grand officialisent
cette stratégie efficace plus qu'il
Ninove
les paillardes ont-ils parle ici sont
les angles immigrés dans l'île
britannique mais la méthode s'applique
partout
j'ai longuement réfléchi au sujet des
angles il va de soi que c'est un tel
peuple il ne faut pas détruire les temps
pour se trouve des idoles mais c'est
idéal elle-même avec de l'eau bénite
qu'on asperges c'est temple puis qu'on
est construit des hôtels et qu'on est
place des reliques car si c'est top sont
de bonne facture il est indispensable
qu'il passe du tout tu te tais des mots
au service du vrai Dieu ainsi voyant que
c'est amplement pas été détruit le cœur
de ce pas drôle on sera à l'erreur
connaissance enfin le vrai Dieu et la
d'Oran il a cours avec plus de confiance
au lieu où il a ses habitudes
la rareté des textes écrits entre le
troisième et le 10e siècle et leur
fiabilité incertaine a toujours rendu
périlleuse l'exploration de cette
période
Rodolphe Glaber et un moine français il
a écrit une chronique qui s'étend des
années 900 jusqu'à 1047
Ali Rodolphe on se rend compte que
contrairement à une idée fausse quoi que
répondu il n'y a jamais eu de peur de
l'an mil ni de concile millénariste
l'église ne diffusé ni terreur Nice
imminente du monde
les hommes de ce temps était toutefois
aussi friand que nous deux mystères
paranormaux
à défaut d'extraterrestres dans des
soucoupe volante leur ciel était parfois
traversée de dragon lumineux
au mois de décembre le samedi soir avant
le jour de la Nativité de seigneur un
étonnant prodige apparu dans l'air
c'était la figure ou plutôt la masse
d'un immense dragon qui sortie des
septentrion gagné le midi avec une
énorme brillance produit je kiffe en
Gaule et frais à presque tous les hommes
qui le vire
témoin de l'effervescence religieuse et
architectural de son temps on doit
surtout à Rodolphe Glaber la célèbre
phrase où il décrit le Blancs-Manteaux
d'église qui couvre peu à peu
près de 3 ans après l'an mil sur presque
toute la terre mais surtout en Italie et
en Gaule au Rénoval et basilic des
églises encore que la plupart était
magnifique et on n'avait guère besoin
mais j'ai pas le chrétien rivaliser les
uns les autres dans l'art de la
magnificence c'était comme si le monde
en se secoue en lui-même avait rejeté
l'ancien pour se vêtir d'un
Blancs-Manteaux d'église
la plupart des églises étaient
magnifiques et n'avait guère besoin de
rénovation
Glaber semble d'écrire vers l'an mil la
même dynamique architecturale que celle
décrite par Grégoire de Tours au 6e
siècle
dès l'Antiquité les druides s'organiser
des gens confréries religieuse et leurs
mœurs très structuré anticipe
étrangement celle de nos moines
médiévaux
reclus dans des abbayes les druides
vivait en effet loin du siècle pour se
consacrer aux études théologiques
d'après l'historien antique Amiens
Marcel
parmi eux supérieur dans la telligence
et selon la règle de Pythagore associée
dans communauté fraternelle les druides
été formé au mystère caché et aux hautes
études en fin méprisant les choses
humaines il proclamait que les âmes sont
immortelles
or les druides avait coutume de tenir
chaque année leur assemblée générale au
pays des Carnutes pour cœur de la Gaule
d'après les historiens grecs Posidonius
en effet chaque année à date fixe sur le
territoire des Carnutes qui passe pour
le centre de toute la Gaule les bruits
de tienne dans un 6 en un lieu consacré
incident et les temps anciens le clergé
paille indisposée d'abbaye druidique
régi par une certaine règle monastique
est le chef-lieu de l'ordre religieux
était quelque part dans l'Orléanais
port sur le territoire des anciens
Carnutes le long de la Loire se dressent
l'abbaye de Fleury
l'abbaye de Fleury est situé à
Saint-Benoît-sur-Loire dans le Loiret
selon les anciens textes et leur été
fondée vers 650
17 époque les moines et applique une
certaine règles de vie en communauté
mais laquelle
la légende veux que des moins de Fleury
soit aller chercher au Mont Cassin en
Italie la dépouille de Saint Benoît de
Nursie mort un siècle plus tôt et de sa
sœur sainte Scholastique
et de rapporter du même coup la fameuse
règle que Benoît aurait jadis lui-même
écrite cette règle dit Bénédictine sera
ensuite en vigueur dans tout le XI dans
[Musique]
maintenant une question se pose faut-il
vraiment croire que des moins de Gaulois
groupe et elle détruit dans confrérie au
pays même des Carnutes on tue besoin de
quiconque pour se créér une règle
monastique
c'est moi Gaulois avait déjà localement
l'expérience des siècles pour établir de
leur propre chef une règle de vie en
communauté compatible avec le
christianisme
que l'on songe que de son côté la
papauté n'avait aucune expérience de la
vie en Master et les préceptes des
Églises d'Orient lui offrait plus un
pieuse idéal qu'une règle pragmatique
il faut temps faut tenir compte d'un
indice révélateur la vie de l'auteur
présumé Benoît de Nursie ne nous est
connu que par l'ogre du pape Grégoire le
Grand
or c'est précisément le pain Grégoire le
Grand il faut qu'il pleut ou qu'il
souhaitable que l'Église s'approprie les
oeuvres païennes lorsqu'elles sont de
bonne qualité
il va de soi qu'il ne faut pas détruire
les temps pour se trouve des idoles mais
c'est Zidane elle-même car si c'est
temples sont de bonne facture il est
indispensable qu'il passe du culte des
démons au service du vrai Dieu
si la règle de Riddick de vie en
communauté était de bonne facture il
était donc indispensable qu'elle passe à
ton culte du vrai Dieu
ce code monastique aura toutefois été
attribué par Grégoire le Grand a un - du
Latium pour en effacer l'origine païenne
la jurisprudence Grégoire le Grand si
l'on peut ainsi la non c'est sans doute
pas limité au temple
pour exemple la liturgie catholique a
récupéré la fête de Samonios cet
automnale des druides pour en faire la
Toussaint et la fête des morts
résumé si la papauté a fait sien des
temples et des fêtes Riddick il est très
probable qu'il en soit de même pour la
première de ces règle monastique
vélo on comprend mieux l'intérêt des
moines de l'abbaye de Fleury de
s'approprier à leur tour les ossements
de Saint-Benoît
comme pour clore un juste retour de la
règle monastique versé véritable aux
auteurs
faisons de l'abbaye un espace autonome
ce code communautaire veut que l'abbé
soit élu par ses frères
et que la vie du couvent s'organise
autour de trois activités la prière
l'étude des textes et le travail manuel
devenue la bibliothèque de la Gaule le
monastère de Fleury jouit de grand
privilège sur les rois mérovingiens puis
carolingien au point d'être la
principale école de formation
intellectuelle du royaume
l'architecture de l'abbaye de Fleury est
en outre remplie de mystère
devant l'entrée ouest de l'église
s'élève une tour Porsche belle massive
unique en son gendre d'environ 16 m de
côté pour 24 m de haut
tour Porsche dans les colonnes sont
coiffées de chapiteau historié où
s'entremêlent savamment ancien mythe
païen et nouvelles croyances chrétienne
[Musique]
un texte rapporte comment à certaines à
Bego cela aurait vers l'an mil fait
bâtir en pierre de taille 7 tours
singulières
enfin l'abbé Gosselin décida de
construire au côté ouest de ce monastère
une tour en pierre de taille que par des
neufs il ferait transporter depuis le
Nivernais comme le chef des artisans en
lui demander quel ouvrage est l'ordonnée
d'entreprendre le bienheureux répondit
tel qu'il soit un exemple pour toute la
Gaule
un exemple pour toute la Gaule avec ses
chapiteau Payen sa bibliothèque de
Charlemagne ça règle bénédictine dans la
région où les druides donné jadis leur
synode annuel
le paysage intemporel des bords de Loire
ajoute encore à la pérennité de l'abbaye
de Fleury chef-d'œuvre du Celtic
médiéval français
quand disparaît la recette aux chrétiens
et quelle en est la cause
au 12e siècle Saint Bernard de Clairvaux
va s'indigner de cet art qu'il juge
indigne de l'Évangile
Bernard décrit avec minutie c'est figure
mythologique sorti tout droit d'un
imaginaire païen et noms de la Bible
ils n'ont compte est certes pas la force
facile Natoire au contraire mais il n'en
comprend ni le sens mais la présence
dans une église
le passage assez long et très instructif
mets dans les cloîtres devant les frères
dans lecture que fait cette monstruosité
ridicule c'est de lait de beauté ou
belle laideur pourquoi ici c'est immonde
singe pourquoi c'est lion féroce
pourquoi ces monstres le centaure
pourquoi c'est comme pourquoi c'est
pourquoi c'est soldat en lutte pourquoi
c'est chasseur qui souffle l'olifant
envoie sous une tête plusieurs corps et
à l'inverse sur un corps plusieurs têtes
ici sur un quadrupède on distingue une
queue de serpent au loin sur un poisson
une tête de quadrupède la une bête se
présente Miss cheval devant mi-chèvre
derrière ici un animal Cornu porte en
arrière de cheval enfin le nom de la
merveille de ces images diverses et
variées partout son tel qu'il est plus
de lire ses marbres que les manuscrits
et de s'occuper tous les jours à
contenter singularité jamais dit et la
loi de Dieu est grand dieu si on a pas
honte de tel si tu connais ton chagrin
de telles dépenses
[Musique]
à ma connaissance aucun texte antérieur
de dresser un inventaire même partielle
des figures type de l'art celtique dans
les églises
Bernard est le premier
ce lundi quelle époque antérieure où
l'on a bâti C sanctuaire l'écrit et est
encore très rare et que dominait la
culture orale
ce contrat édifiant entre une culture
figuratif très structurée et l'absence
totale de source explicatives à l'écrit
pose question
[Musique]
cette coutume du mystère religieux fait
songer Rodrigue qui jadis refusé de
confire à l'écrit leur savoir
théologique pour le réserver uniquement
à ce qui se consacre est aux études
on dit que les étudiants j'apprenne ton
prêt détruit d'un grand nombre de verre
aussi certains reste-t-il 20 ans étudier
mais les trucs d'estime qui ne sais pas
de confier cela à l'écrit
[Musique]
on dirait que le même interdit de
l'écrit prévaut en Gaule chrétienne du
4e ou 11e siècle
les lignes de Saint-Bernard révèle donc
un fait majeur au moment où il écrit ces
lignes au 12e siècle les œuvre qu'il a
sous les yeux ne sont plus du tout
comprise ni par lui ni par les autres
moine
une distance culturelle les sépare
désormais de ce qu'ils ont fait
précédemment les concepteurs et les
bâtisseurs
la raison de ce rejet est un changement
complet de logiciel
porteur d'une culture orale Marcel
topchrétien utilise en effet un logiciel
symbolique d'origine druidique
tandis que Bernard et sa génération
commence E1 utiliser un autre logiciel
totalement différent qui tente à faire
de la bible des saints et des rois la
mesure de toute chose
ce nouveau logiciel en privilégiant
l'écrit en se porte envers les lettres
va créer les universités et Lardy
gothique appeler en ce temps-là au pouce
Francorum loeuvre des Francs
ainsi vers les 11e 12e siècle on passe
culturellement de l'oral à l'écrit
artistiquement du Celtic au gothique et
nationalement de la Gaule à la France
basculement considérable aux églises
celtiques dit romane disséminés sur tout
l'espace nationale succède bientôt les
cathédrales françaises
centralisée au cœur des diocèses
église de l'enracinement rural vers le
cosmopolitisme urbain
les à la source de ce changement de
paradigme dans tout le XI dans il y a
surtout un phénomène géopolitique
on observe en effet que cette
métamorphose culturelle coïncide
exactement avec la croisade
en 1095 au concile de Clermont le
français urbain 2 proclame la croisade
4 ans plus tard Godefroy de Bouillon
conquiert Jérusalem et libère le tombeau
du Christ
1119 et créer l'Ordre du Temple dans la
mission consiste à sécuriser les lieux
saints et protéger les pères
or le code de chevalerie de l'ordre est
écrit par Bernard de Clairvaux
l'auteur a conscience de la nouveauté
historique de ce qui se passe
croisade et milice templière bouleverse
non seulement la vie de Lorient en
saillie mais aussi la mentalité même de
l'Occident
c'est une minute d'un genre nouveau dire
et inconnue des siècles passés par
laquelle on le sent la sur deux choses à
la fois et contre la chair et le sang
est contre les démons céleste
[Musique]
ainsi Saint-Bernard et à la fois le
témoin médiéval le plus précis de l'art
celtique dans les églises à Celtic il
rejette car il ne le comprend pas
et le soutien intellectuel des Templiers
implantés désormais en Orient
Bernard sera même le promoteur de la
deuxième croisade
l'esprit croisade ouvre donc une brèche
énorme dans le temps historique en
connectant soudain l'Occident à Lorient
ce qui n'était plus arrivé depuis la
disparition de l'Empire romain
d'Occident
ce conflit extérieur va orienter et
orientaly's et l'imaginaire des
nouvelles générations les coupant du
même coup de la tradition autochtone
c'est sans va-et-vient entre les deux
rives les croisés vont te dis fier et
promouvoir un nouveau christianisme
centre est désormais sur la Bible fidèle
en cela à la pensée de Saint-Bernard
pour conséquence dans les représentation
artistique du gothique les épisodes de
la Bible quand on rapidement le dessus
pour reléguer la mythologie celtique à
la marge
[Musique]
quelle est donc cette culture
occidentale qui s'étend de l'Antiquité
chrétienne jusqu'au croisades de
Saint-Martin à Godefroy de Bouillon du
4e au 12e siècle
l'architecture mesurer interprète espace
est révélé ainsi l'imaginaire de ceux
qui en sont les créateurs
dans les sanctuaires les représentations
de la recette aux chrétiens sont presque
toujours situées en hauteur
soit sur des chapiteau historié en haut
des colonnes
soit sur des modillons en excroissance
des murs
soit sur des frises courant le long des
murs
ajoutons les baptistère située au sol
la composition plastique de l'art
celtique c'est fort souvent de serrer et
d'entrelacs c'est les divers personnages
ainsi tout l'espace disponible à la
gravure est-il utilisé
[Musique]
la morphologie de l'homme est compris
mais ce qui donne à certains personnages
une allure ramasser
resserrement des figures qui porte le
nom de phobie du vide
cette caractéristique différencie le
celtique du gothique qui offrira au
contraire décor plus espacées alors
juste proportion voir Tropez lancer
elancement des figures qui porte le nom
d'attrait du vide
au cours des siècles on observe ainsi
une évolution intéressante
d'une part l'art plastique va tendre à
détacher de la matière brute le sujet
figure et donc à l'extraire de
l'architecture
d'autre part il va attendre aussi à
personnaliser c'est-à-dire à donner de
plus en plus de singularité au sujet
ainsi les premières églises montre
surtout des gravures en relief le
bas-relief extraite à peine le sujet de
son support
le haut-relief plus profond et en
général plus tardifs long extrait
davantage
façonner dans les éléments porteurs de
l'édifice les personnages sont ici
toujours corps avec l'architecture
[Musique]
et ses personnages humains animaux
végétaux chimériques honte à l'évidence
valeur de symboles d'où la portée
mythologique du Celtic
plus tard au gothique les cathédrales
vont-ils NOVEANT nerigean fréquemment
des statues c'est-à-dire des personnages
autonome
le corps figuris exprès désormais du mur
la rond de bosse s'arrache de la pierre
carrée lettre se libère de
l'architecture pour acquérir si l'on
peut dire une vie propre
l'art du vitrail des tâches aussi les
personnages de la pierre tout en les
intégrant harmonieusement dans les bases
immenses créé entre les murs
douce et verrière lumineuse
quand ton personnage gothique presque
toujours humain et ajuster aux
proportions naturel il rayon d'une
gravité solennelle
beaucoup de ces êtres déploie un port
altier objectif majestueux
le gothique vous un culte particulier à
l'idéal
enfin autre changement majeur la
Renaissance développe à grande échelle
l'art du tableau et son portrait
individualisé
qu'il s'agisse de peinture ou de
sculpture on aura alors quitté le
symbole et l'idéal pour le réalisme et
l'émotion
la différence est flagrante en train
relief celtique une statue gothique et
un tableau Renaissance
une scène inspirée de l'Évangile la
fuite en Égypte
ce chapiteau Celtic figure Joseph tenant
d'une main la bride du cheval de l'autre
la palme
il arbore une barbe bifide
sur le cheval Marie qui porte Jésus sur
ses genoux et assise en amazone
précisément à la manière de l'ancien
déesse gauloise Epona
[Musique]
pour cette posture singulière n'est pas
tirée de l'Évangile qui ne dit rien du
moyen de locomotion
l'enfant Dieu auréolé d'un un bac
Roi-Soleil présente dans sa main gauche
une sorte de petit faire de sa main
droite
dans le ciel 2000 la même main bénie
sentent comme surgit d'une spirale et un
astre en forme de fleur à 6 pétales
avec le Celtic tout est symbole
sur ce vitrail gothique la même scène
devient sobre il n'y a plus d'éléments
mystérieux
et les trois personnages dégage une
esthétique noblesse
enfin ce tableau Renaissance promis une
seule famille beaucoup plus
terre-à-terre
Joseph Marie et même Jésus on les
portrait de Monsieur et Madame tout le
monde
si on suit sur 1000 ans l'art chrétien
dans nos églises au Celtic le héros
figure et appartient à l'architecture et
Confino symbole
gothique il se détache de l'architecture
et confina l'idéal
à la Renaissance il quitte
l'architecture et Confino sensible
Commentry long voyage de l'âme
européenne au fil des siècles d'idées
d'abord par les anciens dieux puis par
les anges chrétien enfin par sa propre
humanité
il va de soi que cette analyse trace
certaines grandes lignes directrices
mais qu'il demeure maintenu en exception
les sujets traités dans les églises
celtiques sont au premier abord des plus
des routes
l'ambiance surnaturel nous rapproche
plus de la Théogonie d'Hésiode ou émerge
du chaos des origines géant Dieu est
rose et chimères que 200-2 l'Évangile
il n'est que 10 entrées pour le voir
[Musique]
le spectateur est saisi par une foule
carnavalesque de personnages improbables
dont le subtil jeu de métamorphose
oscillo marge des espèces connues
une ménagerie de créature fantastique
qui trône en hauteur dominante sur les
tympans les voussures où les chapiteaux
[Musique]
si entremele la forme humaine a d'autres
formes de vie façonnant des monstres
hybrides dans des vision quasi onirique
iconographie du voyage des âmes mélange
incongru où l'homme l'animal est la
plante s'interpénètrent dans des
méandres convulsifs pour créer des
chimères de toutes sortes
le centaure mi-cheval mi-homme
et le Sagittaire avec son arc
[Musique]
Le Griffon est une créature mi-lion
mi-aigle
souvent il encadre un calice
[Musique]
l'homme a parfois un visage de Lyon
et l'oiseau un visage d'homme
des hybrides ont plusieurs visages telle
les Triphon
à l'inverse des monstres sont big or ils
partagent la même tête tout en ayant
deux corps
souvent de Lyon
[Musique]
l'énigmatique sirène est une femme à
queue de poisson
[Musique]
la sirène a parfois deux queues de
poisson comme une métamorphose de ses
propres jambes
[Musique]
des monstres tel serpent des dragons
entre les murs
et des fauves surtout des lions
des lions tiennent une tête humaine
entre leurs pattes
[Musique]
des rinceaux de feuillage des de fruits
sorte de la gueule des lions
[Musique]
7 de Laurens où est très fréquente
on trouve aussi des personnages plus
rassurant tel ce héros viril qui
poursuit a fondé Lyon
[Musique]
outre personnage où est-ce le même cet
homme fait corps avec les branches des
arbres l'homme pavé fusionné avec
l'arbre comme une préfiguration du
Christ en croix
[Musique]
au sein des entre la de feuillage surgit
soudain une tête d'homme ou de bête mais
sans tous évanescente
[Musique]
herbier fantastique d'où jaillissent des
visages
des visages qui peut-être dans certains
cas figure le divin voir Dieu lui-même
[Musique]
Dieu et alors figurer dans sa sereine
sur humanité
Seigneur et mettre de ce carnaval de
créature multiforme
et quel est cet acrobate qui accomplit
une roue avec son corps incurves en son
dos en arrière jusqu'à toucher ses pieds
avec ses mains
home circulaire il fait un saut sur
lui-même sa propre révolution passage
peut-être vers une nouvelle vie
tout se passe comme si ces images
réelles vous les dévoiler non pas la
nature telle qu'elle est si j'ai sous
les yeux mais la force invisible qui
façonnent la nature en mouvement
enfin ce théâtre religieuse s'accompagne
de Things abstrait telle les arcanes
d'une écriture oublié
parmi ces motifs la roue contient en son
centre des rayons ou des pétales de
fleurs en nombre d' hiver
les roues sont parfois groupées la ligne
mais le fait qu'elle soit aussi associée
à des figures suppose qu'elles ont un
sens bien précis peut-être pour désigner
un astre ou une saison
La Croix à 4 branches = ici dans un
cercle semble avoir un sens différent de
la Croix christique qui est un taux ou
une croix latine
l'étoile à huit branches qui forme de
croix double peut représenter la
Résurrection où le solstice d'été
[Musique]
l'hélice ressemble à une étoile mais
avec des branches incurvé tel un soleil
tournant
[Musique]
le double est symétrique se rencontre en
longue vous sur
au côté d'un personnage
avec sa volute en introspection le S
rappel le symbole mathématique de
l'infini
ici les deux S se croiser
dans la continuité du double est-ce
qu'on trouve les spirales elle aussi
presque toujours en duo
les spirales sont extrêmement fréquentes
si tu es en général aux angles haut du
chapiteau et long cadre alors un élément
central
ou une scène complexe
les spirales ne sont pas de simples
éléments de décors elle recèle tu à
l'évidence un sens particulier
[Musique]
avec leur longue tige qui se tire vers
le centre les spirales ressemble tu as
des crosses qu'un prêtre agrippe ici
dans ses mains
crosse et spirale sont des attributs
sacré
ce personnage dominant et probablement
la représentation de Dieu
[Musique]
beaucoup d'autres motifs orne les
églises celtiques telle déranger de
Chevron
ou de demi-cercle
il existe une relation manifeste entre
Cécile abstrait au figuratif et la
science héraldique
Lyon et griffon sont présents aussi bien
dans les églises que sur les écus
dans les églises Celtic l'arbre stylisé
se compose d'un tronc flanqué de 2
branches latérales en spirale
à la floraison une fleur un fruit ou un
astre sur monte l'arbre
ici l'arbre surmonté d'une sphère est
encadrée d'une spirale et de cercle
concentrique
là c'est une feuille en cœur qui réunit
en elle les branches latérales haute
dans un entrelacs de Reims ou et de
pommes de pin
la continuité iconographique est
évidente entre l'arbre sacré où l'homme
arbre de l'art celtique et le Christ en
croix de l'art chrétien
d'où cette scène étonnante the
crucifixion de Dieu sur un arbre avec un
lys à la cime
arbre qui se résume enfin à la célèbre
fleur de lys l'emblème héraldique de la
France des rois chrétiens
on observe en général la recherche de
symétrie dans les compositions comme une
ingénieuse rhétorique des formes
à vrai dire rien n'est laissé au hasard
loin d'être un habillage qui vole c'est
idéogramme Fantin langage codé
l'héritage de CI rosbif stylisé remonte
très loin dans le passé
on en trouve des vestiges de l'âge de
pierre belle les motifs du dolmen de
Gavrinis en Armorique
la poursuite sur le temps long de cette
culture occidentale n'avait pas échappé
à Louis briller historien spécialiste de
l'art
on commence à mieux connaître
aujourd'hui les origines très complète
de c'est tard et on est d'abord frapper
des analogies qu'il présente avec l'art
protohistorique de La Tène c'est à fait
établi par l'archéologie gallo-romaine
que parallèlement à l'art classique
apportées par les Romains l'art
indigènes de la Gaule dans certains
thèmes d'accès de l'âge du bronze et
même des temps néolithique n'a cessé de
se développer avec ses tendances propre
visiter les anciennes église d'Occident
s'est plongé dans le ferrique décor de
je ne sais quelle Atlantique du fond des
âges
à l'évidence ce monde singulier
n'appartient pas à la Bible
en France ce logiciel provient tout
droit de l'imaginaire celtique
dans les églises archaïques sur les
pierres gravées les références
explicites au Nouveau Testament sont
rares
il n'y a parfois rien pour rappeler la
vie pour ton foisonnante du Christ
comme si l'on ne connaissait pas le
texte biblique
la basse antiquité et le au Moyen-Âge
sont-ils les vrais des époques de
culture oral donc peu littéraire
Grégoire de Tours en fait fois c'est
même la première phrase de son œuvre
majeure
la noble culture des lettres tombe en
décadence et plus encore dans les cités
gauloises elle périsse
c'est ce constat alarmant qui l'a incité
à écrire pour la postérité une œuvre
qu'il sait plus civil que religieuse
malheur à nos jours nous qui avons perdu
l'étude des lettres par le public on ne
trouve pas d'intellectuels pour publier
dans le civil les expos à présent ces
choses et d'autres je les ai donc
considéré et de suite raconter pour la
mémoire du passé afin qu'elle part va
c'est la connaissance de la postérité
fût-ce dans un langage rude
ces représentations minérales sont donc
à étudier le plus souvent sans le
recours à la Bible
d'une époque qui savent où il est très
il serait temps en effet un à chronique
de vouloir et trouver un tout pris dans
les compositions plastique des
références explicite à l'Évangile voir à
l'Ancien Testament
[Musique]
l'un des problèmes les plus importants
auxquels sur l'analyse de la recette aux
chrétiens et la datation car la pierre
se prête mal à la chronologie
à quand remonte telle ou telle of 4e 6e
8e 11e siècle
du 4e au 12e siècle la Gaule concert de
nombreuses édifice d'époque romaine
beaucoup finissent à l'abandon ton
Sandrine alors on en réutiliser les
matériaux
cette opération de remploi s'avère bien
plus rentable que de passer commande de
nouvelles pierre de taille
toutes les architectures délaissés
parfois des immenses deviennent auto de
carrière à ciel ouvert
vers l'an 800 l'empereur Charlemagne
fait construire dans sa nouvelle
capitale une basilique
pour cela il se fournit en matériaux
antique
les pires de teint ils proviennent
d'anciennes murailles de Verdun
statut proviennent de plus loin encore
d'Italie
la basilique d'Aix-la-Chapelle serai
donc en partie 1re emploi hétéroclite de
matériaux anciens comme le constate
l'historien Louis-Bréguet
pour construire c'est basilique
d'Aix-la-Chapelle Charlemagne fait
démolir les fortifications
gallo-romaines de Verdun et il tira les
revêtement de marbre et les colonnes de
l'ancien palais impérial de Ravenne il
fait même venir de cette ville statue de
Théodoric qu'il donne la sensation pour
la tienne
sur certaines églises ont des c'est des
différences de style architectural de
teinte ou d'usure de la pierre
cette bigarrure suppose un assemblage
tardive d'éléments disparate plus ancien
les Rompois concerne plus encore les
oeuvres artistiques des sacrées ainsi
des chapiteaux sont renier sur les côté
voir raccourci
des figures sont mal orienté peu visible
preuve que le originel avait été sculpté
pour un autre emplacement donc elle est
plus ancien que l'Église actuel
souvent toutefois l'architecte aura pris
soin d'intégrer Romieu leur emploi dans
la nouvelle architecture
les traces de remploi devient alors
quasi indétectable
le fait que ses œuvre religieuse et et
et reemployer ne doit pas faire oublier
le réel antériorité
de fondation hors fondation les remploi
successifs perpétuent ainsi la culture
des ancêtres
église et monastère sont des
conservatoires artistiques sur les
siècles même antérieure alors fondation
de ces figures la correcte datation à
retenir et donc celle de leur façonnage
réelle et non celle de leurs emplois
ultérieurs
de la basse antiquité aux croisades
c'est-à-dire de 300 à 11 ans ils ont été
fondé partout
et la plupart ont été remodeler au cours
des siècles
sur recyclage constant des matériaux
aura pour conséquence de donner au
Moyen-Âge un certain air de famille
et cet air de famille doit beaucoup
palard druidique de l'ancien goal
l'évêque historien Grégoire de Tours
avec un bisaïeul homonyme du nom de
Grégoire
compte d'Autun se Grégoire Nevers 446
durant sa jeunesse il gouverne la tribu
des Hédouin puis converti au
christianisme il devient évêque de
langue en 506
le diocèse de langues comprends alors la
cité de Dijon
pour à Dijon les païens avait coutume
d'apporter des offrandes au tombeau d'un
mystérieux personnage qui en retour
accomplissez leur prière
comme c'est dans un grand sarcophage
qu'on avait t'enfermer ce défunt les
hommes de ce temps et notamment le
bienheureuse et la Grégoire pensais
qu'on y avait placé quelques pas y a en
effet les ruraux venez la s'acquitter de
leur veux et ce qu'ils avaient demandé
se réaliser rapidement
un jour un païen dépose un cierge auprès
du tombeau en récompense des bien fait
reçu par le défunt puis son retourne
chez lui
un jeune garçon avait tout servi la
scène il descend alors au tombeau dans
le but d'éteindre le cierge et de le
volet
[Musique]
mets le divin défunt possède un serpent
qui garde les trésors que les fidèles
viennent remettre en offrande
l'enfant et en descendu voici qu'un
serpent d'une taille extraordinaire
venant d'un autre côté entoura le cierge
l'enfant apeuré revint sur sais pas
putin tu as deux ou trois fois de
s'emparer du siège mais il ne plus
devant le serpent qui faisait d'obstacle
ce divin personnage associé à un serpent
semble désigner l'ancien Dieu celtique
car nous notre maître d'un reptile qui
tient ta main
le musée même de Dijon présenter un
personnage 13 approches en
[Musique]
comme souvent l'église à consacrer le
temple du dieu local au nouveau saint à
honorer
c'est ainsi que l'ancien sanctuaire
païen est devenu le tombeau de saint
Bénigne
saint Bénigne c'est-à-dire le bon Saint
serai mort Martyrs à Dijon vers 179 il
est l'apôtre de la Bourgogne
ça fait le 1er novembre coïncide avec la
fête de Riddick de Samonios ou selon la
coutume se réunissaient vivant est mort
bénigne apparaître en vision
surnaturelle à l'évêque de Langres et
lui enjoint de reconstruire son tombeau
frappé de cette vision l'évêque seront
tot bienheureux sépulcre les anciens
vous avez fait là vous de la crypte et
comme elle tombe et en ruine le
bienheureux pontife en rénova la voûte
avec de beaux matériaux sans délai sur
cette crypte il donna entre d'édifier
une grande basilique
[Musique]
ce sont ses œuvre archaïque que l'on
rencontre aujourd'hui dans la crypte de
la cathédrale Saint-Bénigne de Dijon
au des colonnes les chapiteau historié
décrivent des scènes mythologiques à
forte teneur païenne
malgré l'érosion du temps on y devine
Centaure félin est volatile
[Musique]
humanoide énigmatique
et de mystérieux hiéroglyphe feuillage
hélice roue spirale
pour dater c'est chapiteau avec
exactitude il faudrait disposer d'un
disque parallèle datable et tenter des
recoupements
hors des indices existent
en 481 le roi des Francs Childéric fait
inhumé dans un tumulus non loin de
Tournai en Belgique cumulus qui fait des
couverts en 753
parmi les ornements l'anneau sigillaire
du roi grave et qu'il dirait qui
régissent roi Childéric indique sans
doute possible son propriétaire
des pièces d'or frappées en l'honneur de
l'empereur byzantin et non situe
l'époque et confirme la date de la mort
de Childéric en 481
on trouve aussi le poignard du roi et
une trentaine de bijoux d'étranges
interprété comme des abeilles
enfin il y a surtout une applique qui
présente un poitrail de taureau et sur
le front de ce taureau insigne en helice
avec 9 branches
[Musique]
ce signe très précis se retrouve presque
à l'identique dans la crypte de
Saint-Denis une hélice à branche
on peut supposer que les 2 pictogrammes
sont de la même époque et les chapiteaux
de la crypte dijonnaise de l'époque de
Childéric et de Grégoire de langue
autour de Lens un sens
l'archéologie confirmer si parfaitement
le texte de Grégoire de Tours
la piste ne s'arrête pas là après que la
clip a été rénové Grégoire de langue
veux-tu faire remettre le sarcophage de
Saint-Denis Horse sarcophage et si lourd
que 3 paires de bovidé sont incapables
de le tracter
le fait est que ce sarcophage était si
robuste cas ce moment trois paires
double nœud pour le tirer après un long
retard et ne trouvant pas comment le
faire rentrer dedans Saint-Grégoire à la
lueur des cierges cette somme c'est et
le sarcophage à la tête de prêtre pouce
de pied est où le transport The Last Man
dans l'Afrique
il est révélateur que le seul animal
évoqué autour de la crypte soit le
bovidé
on note sur le même chapiteau à gauche
et à l'emplacement équivalent de
l'hélice la présence d'un petit
quadrupède lever dans trois cercles
concentriques
ainsi la crypte de Saint-Bénigne est le
tumulus de Childéric présent des thèmes
identiques
dans les deux cas un mort de hautes
fonctions droit
simple repose dans un sépulcre sacré
tumulus crypte il est associé au bovidé
et aller lis à 9 branches
mon auto si la Trinité insistant de la
crypte qu'il s'agisse du texte ou des
figures 3 paires de beuh 3 claire Bening
et de prêtres trois cercles
concentriques autour du petit quadrupède
même les lis avec ses 9 branches et une
trinité de Trinité
sinon poursuivre l'enquête on peut ton
corps remonter le temps et confirmer
l'origine celtique de cette scène
l'association précise de la mort de
l'hélice et du Taureau se rencontre en
effet sur le chaudron celtique de gavé
strip contemporain du Christ
la plaque du fond présente un taureau
mort avec sur son front une hélice à 5
branches
à quelques détails près 5 branches au
lieu de 9 cette scène anticipe
l'applique du tombeau de Childéric
autres indices date et de l'Antiquité
païenne la pierre d'Agassac en
Haute-Garonne présente un relief
richement illustré en bas un taureau
marin nage entre deux poissons
la tête du Taureau est surmontée d'une
sorte de roue dentée
la scène aquatique et surnaturel
témoigne peut-être du passage de l'âme
vers l'au-delà
en résumé on retrouve dans la tombe de
Childéric dans la crypte de Dijon sur le
chaudron de garder ce truc est sur la
stèle d'Agassac des similitudes précise
qui associe le taureau une roue et la
mort
ce n'était pas un celte mais sa tribu
Frank installé en Gaule de longue date
c'était déjà familiariser avec les
Gaulois et même avec le christianisme
j'ai été en effet connu en personne
Sainte-Geneviève la grande figure
féminine et catholique du 5e siècle
l'enterrement de Childéric a
probablement été accompagné d'un décor
mystique et d'une espérance en la vie
après la mort
d'où auprès de sa dépouille des symboles
celtiques similaire à se trouver soit
sur le chaudron druidique de garder ce
truc soit dans la crypte de Dijon
[Musique]
tout se passe donc comme si nos
chapiteau c'est un langage codé
d'origine celtique un langage Danton
s'est servi pour transfert en images nos
croyances dans l'au-delà
les auteurs antiques m'ont jamais eu
aucun mal à rapprocher voir assimiler du
romains des dieux grecs je sais Jupiter
Athéna et Minerve Hermès et Mercure
Mia incorporer un nouveau personnage
telle les Grecs Apollon et Hercule dans
le panthéon romain
le transférer simple car les deux
mythologie sont compatibles
plus exactement il s'agit de mythologie
poétique
mets les deux Celtic se sont toujours
montré réfractaire à ce type d'exercice
pourquoi
peut-être ne s'agit-il pas de mythologie
politique à proprement parler
il existe certes des points communs la
tribu du tonnerre rapproche le latin
Jupiter du celte Taranis mais c'est la
tribu qui les rapproche pas forcément la
conception divine que gauloise romain
avait respectivement du roi céleste
on aurait le même problème avec le
christianisme si l'on voulait rapprocher
par exemple Dieu le Père et Jupiter le
Christ Hercule la Vierge est Demeter ou
le Saint-Esprit est Hermès
des similitudes mais seulement de
surface
il y a donc une différence d'essence et
de buts entre une mythologie poétique
grecque ou romaine et une mythologie
mystique c'est-à-dire une croyance
druidique ou chrétienne
autre différence entre monde
gréco-romain est mon Celtic le mode de
transcription
la civilisation gréco-romaine se sert
d'un alphabet phonétique pour transcrire
sa culture cela donne des livres
dès lors l'art plastique relief
sculpture mosaïque occupe ce qui reste
d'expressivité
imiter la nature
d'où le culte de la beauté extérieure et
des chef-d'œuvre qui Vista la
reproduction idéale des êtres et des
choses
laver corps humain avec son canon
classique figure la forme et se limite
aux visible n'ayant pas devient
intérieur il n'offre donc aucun message
en lui-même
de civilisation celtique au contraire
refuse de transcrire par un alphabet
phonétique sa croyance culturelle il n'y
a pas de livre la culture repose alors
sur la transmission orale
dès lors c'est l'art plastique lui-même
qui codifie la culture
ce langage visuel rempli le rôle
d'écriture sauf qu'au lieu de tracer des
sons ce sont des images codées qui
fournissent l'information religieuse
les Celtes transcript en images saintes
ce qui n'écrivent pas en alphabet
ce culte mystique ce parent conséquences
de symbole d'hiver et précis très
fréquent par exemple sur les pierres
tombales pomme de pin
croissant de lune
volutes étoiles œuf housse faire
[Musique]
des symboles que l'on retrouvera souvent
dans l'art celtique des églises du au
Moyen-Âge
[Musique]
le concept de culture prend tout à
l'heure à sens très différents voir
opposer
la culture gréco-romaine est laïque
c'est une mythologie terrestre
la culture celtique et religieuse c'est
une mythologie spirituelle chargé
d'espérance dans l'au-delà donc une
croyance mystique
le terme de mythologie peut donc
recouvrir des sens très nuancée
en résumé si la religion des bruits de
repos sur une croyance mystique ou une
mythologie du salut de l'âme on comprend
son éloignement de la culture
gréco-romaine
et sa proximité avec le christianisme
dans la goule profonde jamais romanisé
le culte des anciens Dieu est toujours
resté vivace
l'archéologie on observe une
recrudescence au 3e siècle donc pendant
l'Empire Gaulois
[Musique]
mets la basse antiquité la Gaule
commence à passer de l'Arselle tôt Payen
à l'Arselle topchrétien
[Musique]
et ce sont ces images et ses symboles
qui au cours des siècles suivants vont
être utilisés pour la codification des
idées religieuses dans les premières
église d'Occident